hey guys it's March third Mary switch
miss ho ho I've got Joey's copy because
I had to give Rob's back and he was very
mad about it so thanks for telling him
guys anyway I've got your top five new
stories of the week let's go
at number five for honor got a big old
patch that buff specific fighters this
past Tuesday for honor got an update
that dropped on pc ps4 and xbox one
bringing with it a bunch of changes
arguably the biggest changes ubisoft
reverting the guard break move to how it
performed in the games beta this means
you can now counter an enemy's guard
Rick by using the same move yourself a
few of the game spiders have also
undergone changes as part of the update
Valkyrie is getting buffed with quicker
and more powerful attacks while a couple
of peacekeepers moves have seen their
range increase additionally bots joining
an in-progress match of dual brawl or
elimination will be dead until the round
is over the patch contains a number of
bug fixes and minor tweaks check out the
full patch notes on gamespot com at
number 4 overwatch got a new hero this
week a robot named Arista Blizzard
revealed the newest character to
overwatch his roster Reesa Reesa is a
ten class character whose gameplay is
engineered around protection her weapon
is the fusion driver an automatic cannon
that deals constant damage but slows her
movement speed her alternate fire is
halt which launches a charge that she
can detonate to slow enemies and pull
them towards the explosion her abilities
include fortify which reduces the damage
she takes and makes her immune to action
impairing effects and protective barrier
a stationary barrier that can be
deployed to block enemy attacks her
ultimate is super charger which launches
a device that buffs damage done by any
teammates in its line of sight the
device itself can be destroyed by
enemies you can try out a recent now on
the PC versions public test realm check
out gameplay plus all of our recent
skins emotes and highlight intros over
on gamespot number 3 Xbox is getting a
Netflix like subscription service called
Xbox game pass Microsoft has announced
Xbox game pass a service that offers
quote unlimited access to over 100 great
xbox one and xbox 360 titles as part of
a monthly subscription of 999 per month
the service is expected to launch late
spring 2017 will be available only for
Xbox one games include halo 5 guardians
payday 2 NBA 2k16 and Lego Batman new
games will be added to the catalog of
games available on the service every
month as others are removed Xbox Live
Gold is not required to play xbox past
games though you'll still need gold
membership to play multiplayer in those
titles those that are part of the Xbox
insider program can now test the xbox
game pass in the Alpha preview ring with
a very limited number of titles number 2
and video revealed this baby at GDC the
gtx 1080 TI can I keep it nvidia
officially announced the geforce gtx
1080 TI on tuesday at GDC senior VP of
GPU engineering John album revealed the
architecture and expected performance of
the company's new flagship graphics card
claiming an aggregate improvement of
thirty five percent over the GTX 1080
and video claims it exhibits the biggest
jump in performance for a TI branded
card and video says that the
temperatures will also see an
improvement by staying five degrees
Celsius cooler under the same noise
levels as its non TI counterpart the gtx
1080 TI is set to launch the week of
march six for six hundred and
ninety-nine dollars the standard gtx
1080 received a price cut and is now
available for 499 dollars for more specs
on the 1080 TI check out gamespot com
and your top story of the week the
announcement of middle-earth shadow of
war on Monday Warner Brothers announced
the sequel to middle-earth shadow of
Mordor titled shadow of war we got an
epic announcement trailer containing cg
video but the first gameplay is slated
to arrive on March 8th shadow war is
developed by monolith productions the
game is set between the events of The
Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings the
first games praised nemesis system also
returns overall monolith is promising a
richer more personal and expansion world
for shadow of war shadow of war will be
available on ps4 xbox one and pc and
launches on august 22nd in North America
and August 25th and Europe and those are
your top five stories of the week and
also if you want to see a movie this
weekend I highly recommend seeing Logan
it's incredible you can check out our
reactions video to it over on gamespot
universe that's where we keep all of our
movie videos so go check it out and I'll
see you there